my oldest son I coached his um baseball
team when he was seven years old when I
went out at night every now and then I
still did a drug called ecstasy one
night it was like 3: in the morning and
my brother was like uh you get a coach
in the morning it was an 8: a.m. game
and I said I know I go I I I go I don't
want to I don't want to sleep through it
if I go to sleep and he goes you know
the only way not to sleep through it
take another
pill so I took another pill and and and
uh before the game me and the other
coach met at home plate you
know and I gave him a hug he was like
why you hugging me
dude I was like I just want to have a
good game buddy you know what I
mean yeah but good luck with those kids
yeah yeah yeah